going to turn now to Ukraine where new
Russian attacks hit civilians over the
weekend this despite reported Intel that
suggested Russia's forces were weakening
Ukraine's military has also reported to
be running short of weapons and
ammunition Holly Williams visited this
Airfield where Ukrainian Pilots are
fighting on she joins us now from
Ukraine once again Holly good morning
Tony most people in this country are
Orthodox Christians and they celebrated
Easter over the weekend but despite that
Ukraine says Russia continued to strike
its cities including slaviansk where
Ukrainian officials say the death toll
has now reached 10.
in the small city of sloviansk people's
homes and lives have been reduced to
dust
Ukraine says Russian missiles rained
down on slaviansk we don't know what
their target was but what they hit here
was an apartment building full of
civilians
Ukraine wants to stop its people being
slaughtered like this and documents
recently leaked from the Pentagon appear
to show that Ukrainian air defenses are
dangerously depleted
but they'll soon be getting a patriot
air defense system from the U.S with
more on the way from Europe
meanwhile there are new signs that
Russia's military is faltering some of
the leaked documents show Russian
Special Forces have been decimated by
The Invasion according to the Washington
Post
bolstered by new weapons a Ukrainian
counter-offensive against Russian forces
is expected to launch in the next few
weeks and at this Airfield hidden
amongst Farmland we were taken to see
some of their most valuable assets
cranian helicopter gunships
fly 20 feet above the ground to avoid
detection
targeting Russian positions it's quite
dangerous but
this tactics this works very well Nicola
flies bombing runs on machines that rely
heavily on Old soviet-era technology
they get the job done he told us but
they need more It's never enough never
It's never enough it's for sure it's
never enough
there's been a lot of speculation that
Ukraine's counter-offensive could be
hampered or even delayed by the leak of
those U.S government documents but
publicly at least Ukrainian officials
have downplayed their impact Vlad
Harley Williams in Ukraine for us Holly
thank you very much